se volvieron escasos durante los últimos
dos años y a corto plazo los turistas
podrían seguir ausentes una consecuencia
de la pandemia y las restricciones que
ésta conllevó como resultado se espera
que la industria turística mundial
pierda otros dos mil millones de dólares
en 2021 una estimación similar a las
pérdidas en 2020 de vestir el mejor año
del sector turístico en términos de
visitantes e ingresos fue 2019 y el peor
fue 2020 no hay duda está claro esta es
la crisis histórica de la industria
turística la crisis entre
el año 2021 ha tenido sus altibajos en
el primer semestre del año el sector
turístico seguía de capa caída se
recuperó en junio hasta septiembre a
nivel mundial hubo 76 por ciento menos
de turistas que en 2019 una pérdida del
65 por ciento en eeuu 69 en europa y 95
por ciento en la región asia-pacífico
sin embargo la organización mundial del
turismo es optimista especialmente para
hoy podemos decir que sabemos más sobre
el virus hay más preparación en cuanto
al aspecto sanitario en muchos países la
vacunación está aquí por lo que hay
muchas nuevas oportunidades y soluciones
digitales para controlar el flujo de
turistas muchos tu control de foster's
pero la pandemia ha dejado un
aprendizaje no hay que apresurarse a
cantar victoria la nueva variante
sudafricana podría complicar aún más la
frágil recuperación del sector